[未知] hello，
[未知] 大家好，
[未知] 我是西葛西，
[未知] 作为一个二十多年的老军迷，
[未知] 我亲历了中国航母，
[未知] 从无到有、
[未知] 从弱到强的全过程。
[未知] 零零一辽宁舰破解了航母有无的难题，
[未知] 完成了技术积累与人才培养。
[未知] 零零二山东舰实现了自主设计建造的突破，
[未知] 夯实了常规动力航母的工业基础。
[未知] 零零三福舰舰跨越式采用电磁弹射技术，
[未知] 拉近了与美国航母的代差。
[未知] 中国已经掌握了大型常规动力航母的全链条技术，
[未知] 目前正在大连造船厂建造的新型航母，
[未知] 要从动力上有所突破，
[未知] 大概率成为我国首艘核动力航母的过渡性试验平台。
[未知] 在此基础上，
[未知] 要想实现对美国福特级航母的超越，
[未知] 可能还需要再发展一个型号零零五型。
[未知] 未来零零五航母的设计建造必须立足扬长避短、
[未知] 迭代突计，
[未知] 聚焦核动力电磁弹射舰体设计防御体系四大核心。
[未知] 同时，
[未知] 配套发展新一代舰载机构，
[未知] 建有人家无人协同作战体系，
[未知] 才能真正实现领跑全球。
[未知] 那么今天就跟大家开个脑洞来定议一下后航母时代的超级平台零零五型核动力航母 CVN 二零。
[未知] 那么你们觉得我国第一艘核动力航母是江苏舰还是广东舰呢？
[未知] 请大家评论区留言。
[未知] 最近，
[未知] 熬夜剪辑视频更新，
[未知] 整个人腰酸背痛，
[未知] 出去爬个山松松筋骨，
[未知] 关节却像生了锈一动，
[未知] 却咔咔错里，
[未知] 现真的老了。
[未知] 关节灵活性早就大不如前，
[未知] 查了一下才知道年龄越大，
[未知] 关氨糖流失越严重，
[未知] 才发觉老妈情况就更让人揪心，
[未知] 毕竟年纪更大了，
[未知] 关节问题更突出，
[未知] 疼痛也不跟家里说，
[未知] 这也让我明白，
[未知] 关节养护要趁早多一分保护就少一分摔倒受伤的风险。
[未知] 如果你家人有关节不舒服的，
[未知] 可以试试这款酷冻氨糖小白管我妈也在用老金主了，
[未知] 效果很不错，
[未知] 里面添加了氨糖、
[未知] 软骨素骨胶原蛋白都是关节，
[未知] 必须营养能精准靶向受损，
[未知] 关节激活软骨细胞新生加速滑液分泌，
[未知] 让行动变得轻快自如，
[未知] 还添加人参、
[未知] 山筋车等植物舒缓因子，
[未知] 可快速缓解，
[未知] 关节肌肉不适，
[未知] 推荐它主要是太方便了，
[未知] 哪里不舒服，
[未知] 涂一涂三到五分钟就缓解，
[未知] 且不含药物激素成分，
[未知] 温和老人用着放心，
[未知] 透皮，
[未知] 吸收是口服的两倍，
[未知] 能有效改善，
[未知] 关节肌肉不适，
[未知] 老妈跳广场舞都带着关节不疼了，
[未知] 活动利索了，
[未知] 能自在做喜欢的事。
[未知] 现在价格优惠拍两只立减两百加，
[未知] 每只一百毫升，
[未知] 能用两个多月，
[未知] 性价比高，
[未知] 家里老人关节不舒服的去评论区链接看看，
[未知] 按需求入手，
[未知] 给家人实在的呵护。
[未知] 首先就是舰体的设计与甲板优化设计，
[未知] 舰体与甲板布局直接影响舰载机搭载量、
[未知] 调度、
[未知] 效率与生存能力。
[未知] 一是优化舰导设计，
[未知] 采用小型化一体化舰导，
[未知] 叫福特级舰导更小，
[未知] 减少甲板占用面积，
[未知] 同时集成相控阵雷达电子站系统通信系统，
[未知] 提升舰导的综合作战能力，
[未知] 采用隐身设计，
[未知] 优化舰导外形，
[未知] 降低雷达反射截面积。
[未知] 二是增加甲板面积，
[未知] 甲板全长三百四十米，
[未知] 甲板最宽八十五米。
[未知] 电子甲板角度调整为十二度，
[未知] 避免舰载机起降冲突，
[未知] 扩大升降机载重和面积，
[未知] 以便可以搭载六代舰载机，
[未知] 并提升应急出动能力，
[未知] 优化弹药升降机设计，
[未知] 采用模块化、
[未知] 自动化升降机，
[未知] 提升弹药运输效率，
[未知] 并增加智能辅助挂弹车，
[未知] 缩短舰载机挂弹时间。
[未知] 三是扩大机库容量。
[未知] 中国航母机库不同于美国随船体变化的机库，
[未知] 目前依然延续前苏联长方形机库。
[未知] 所以要尽量提升机库面积，
[未知] 并叫福特级增加百分之十，
[未知] 同时增强智能 AI 维修系统，
[未知] 提升舰载机核护效率。
[未知] 四是增加智能牵引机，
[未知] 并采用尽 i 系统辅助管理甲板以及机库的调度，
[未知] 让舰载机出动效率更高。
[未知] 其次，
[未知] 就是动力系统，
[未知] 无线续航与高功率输出，
[未知] 是未来航母的关键。
[未知] 零零五可以采用第四代核能技术，
[未知] 如铅臂冷却堆或高温气冷堆的建用化版本，
[未知] 具有更高的安全性，
[未知] 且寿命期内无需更换核燃料。
[未知] 四、
[未知] 合增压直流综合电力系统 MVDC 这是中国目前处于世界领先地位的技术。
[未知] 零零五型应取消传统液压和机械传动，
[未知] 实现全舰电力灵活分配。
[未知] 这不仅能支撑更稳定的电磁弹射和拦阻系统，
[未知] 更关键的是能为未来的高能激光武器、
[未知] 电磁垂直发射系统和氧化加相控阵雷达等耗能系统，
[未知] 提供源源不断的电力供应。
[未知] 电磁弹射是航母舰载机出动效率的核心支撑福舰舰的电磁弹射系统以实现突破故障率远低于福特级零零五。
[未知] 航母需在此基础上进一步迭代，
[未知] 让储能速度更快，
[未知] 实现高效可靠、
[未知] 多适配的目标。
[未知] 一是增加弹射位数量设计四条电磁弹射器分布于舰手与斜角甲板较福特级的四条弹射器，
[未知] 进一步优化布局，
[未知] 减少舰载机调度冲突，
[未知] 提升出动效率目标，
[未知] 实现日军出动架次一百六十架以上，
[未知] 远超福特级的一百二十架，
[未知] 实际仅达百分之六十二，
[未知] 是优化弹射功率调节范围，
[未知] 既能适配歼三五六代舰载机等重型战机的满油满弹弹射，
[未知] 也能适配无人预警机、
[未知] 中程辽机等轻型装备。
[未知] 三是集成电磁阻拦系统与电磁弹射系统协同联动，
[未知] 优化阻拦力度，
[未知] 调节适配不同重量的舰载机，
[未知] 减少舰载机降落时的损耗，
[未知] 提升舰载机使用寿命。
[未知] 然后是防御体系，
[未知] 三代海战中航母面临反舰导弹、
[未知] 无人机和潜艇等多重威胁。
[未知] 而零零五航母需构建远中近三层防御体系，
[未知] 一是核动力带来的电力优势，
[未知] 集成新型防御武器。
[未知] 一是远程防御搭载一套电磁垂直发射系统，
[未知] 携带远程防空导弹，
[未知] 射程达到四百公里以上，
[未知] 可拦截来袭的反舰弹道导弹巡航导弹与战机。
[未知] 二是近程防御集成海红旗时，
[未知] 改进型防空导弹，
[未知] 与近防炮系统拦截，
[未知] 突破远程防御的导弹与无人机。
[未知] 三是近程防御部署舰载高能激光导弹利用核动力提供的充足电力，
[未知] 实现对低空无人机、
[未知] 小型导弹的精准拦截，
[未知] 激光武器功率达到三百千瓦。
[未知] 以上可快速摧毁来袭目标，
[未知] 而真正让敌人不敢轻易攻击。
[未知] 我航母的是要携带可搭载战术核武器的弹道，
[未知] 反舰导弹，
[未知] 让敌人不敢轻易出手。
[未知] 反潜防御方面则要交给我之前设定的零七八反潜专用舰艇，
[未知] 利用有人无人反潜机以及水下反潜无人潜航器。
[未知] 对潜艇进行反击。
[未知] 最后，
[未知] 舰载机的设定一定要构建有人家无人协同作战体系。
[未知] 目前，
[未知] 我国福舰舰已搭载空警六百固定翼，
[未知] 有人预警机解决了舰载预警机的有无问题，
[未知] 但有人预警机存在续航时间短、
[未知] 执勤风险高、
[未知] 部署成本高的短板。
[未知] 未来，
[未知] 无人预警机将成为零零五航母的核心预警装备，
[未知] 实现全天候长航时广覆盖的态势感知零零五航母配套的无人预警机，
[未知] 应基于空警六百的技术基础，
[未知] 采用小型化、
[未知] 隐身化设计，
[未知] 降低雷达反射截面机可通过电磁弹射器快速起飞，
[未知] 搭载新型相控阵雷达探测距离达到五百公里以上，
[未知] 可同时跟踪一百个以上目标，
[未知] 具备对隐身战机超低空导弹的探测能力，
[未知] 续航时间达到二十四小时以上，
[未知] 远超有人预警机的六到八小时，
[未知] 可实现全天候执勤，
[未知] 减少有人预警机的部署。
[未知] 压力集成卫星通信系统与双向数据链可将探测到的目标信息，
[未知] 实时传输给航母编队，
[未知] 实现信息共享，
[未知] 为舰载机驱逐舰提供精准引导，
[未知] 同时具备电子战能力，
[未知] 可干扰敌方雷达与通信系统提升航母编队的电子对抗能力。
[未知] 零零五航母配套的六代无垂尾舰载机。
[未知] 核心设计要点是隐身化、
[未知] 智能化、
[未知] 多用途，
[未知] 一是采用无垂尾布局，
[未知] 彻底取消传统垂尾，
[未知] 具备全向隐身能力，
[未知] 隐身性能远超 f 三五 c 雷达反射截面机可控制在零点零零一平方米以内。
[未知] 二是搭载涡扇十五改进行的二维矢量发动机，
[未知] 降低红外隐身能力。
[未知] 三是集成人工智能系统，
[未知] 可与无人舰载机中程辽机协同作战，
[未知] 提升作战灵活性，
[未知] 作为穿透制空打击的核心装备。
[未知] 未来舰载机体系要根据不同任务进行自由搭配。
[未知] 在这里，
[未知] 希格西有几个观点。
[未知] 第一就是执行穿透制空引击，
[未知] 对方核心目标任务，
[未知] 可采用六代机携带大型无人机方案，
[主播] 大型无人机方案，大型无人机可携带反舰导弹进行攻击，而六代机则可以携带远程防空导弹，如霹雳16或17这种超过400公里的空空导弹。
[未知] 大型无人机可携带反舰导弹进行攻击，
[未知] 而六代机则可以携带远程防空导弹，
[未知] 如霹雳十六或十七这种超过四百公里的。
[主播] 利用无人预警机或大型无人机，在前方利用双向数据链结合A射B导，对敌空中预警机或加油机进行击杀。第二种是舰队防空和反击任务，可使用六代机加智空无人机加无人预警机的组合，对敌隐身战机。
[主播] 无人机或亚因素反舰导弹进行拦截，智空无人机和预警机相互配合，而六代机作为重要空中指挥节点，达到真正的未来空战ODA3.0版本。
[主播] 第三种组合就是对路以及相关岛屿的作战，可采用无人预警机电子弹版本加歼35加攻击21的组合形式。
[主播] 无人的攻击21可携带精确指导炸弹巡飞弹，对敌方地面目标，尤其是针对敌方防空系统，作为诱饵吸引火力，为有人舰载机开辟攻击通道。
[主播] 无人预警机则负责电子干扰与压制对方的雷达，而歼35可以携带新型反辐射导弹对敌重要雷达目标进行打击。
[主播] 深入内陆后，攻击21可携带空中加油吊舱，为舰载机进行空中加油，提升舰载机的航程与作战半径。
[主播] 最后在反潜作战上，因自身携带反潜直升机直20数量有限，个人觉得可以根据任务重点，临时搭配一组固定翼反潜机加无人反潜机的组合，或者临时搭配一条大型反潜舰进行反潜。
[主播] 这样可以做到更加灵活的舰载机组合，综上，005航母要实现对美国福特级的超越。
[主播] 核心逻辑并非盲目追求技术堆砌，而是立足我国航母发展的技术基电，规避福特级的创新陷阱。
[主播] 实现核动力可靠化，弹射高效化，防御立体化，同时构建有人家无人协同舰载机体系，以可靠性优先，实战性为王为原则。
[主播] 打造更贴合我国国防需求的超级核动力航母。
[主播] 从技术层面看，目前正在大连造船厂建造的核动力航母，大概率成为我国首艘核动力航母的过渡性试验平台。
[主播] 并以此为基础，通过验证六代舰载机，无人舰载机已取得突破性进展，才可以建造真正的12万吨级航母。
[主播] 小步快跑才是攀登科技高峰最稳妥的道路。
[主播] 所以004可能在甲板设计。
[主播] 动力方面和美国福特级相当，而005航母才是后福特时代的超级。
[主播] 它的建成服役，其综合战力将全面碾压蓝星任何航母，成为全球最先进的航空母舰。
[主播] 而配套舰载机的发展也将推动我国海空作战体系实现质的飞跃。
[主播] 最后005的命名花落谁家呢？请大家评论区留言。